en l'espace de quatre jours nous allons
exécuter une série non pas d'un
mais de deux mais de 3,4 aux quatre
coins du monde nous partirons vers le
sur les couches on
sait très exactement ce que je dis
ludwig militaire un super cracker de
coffre il a à son actif une vie entière
d' expertise théorique
mais n'a jamais utilisé ses compétences
dans la vie réelle jusqu'à aujourd'hui
trop sympa de faire votre connaissance
et elle te rejoindre la bande
on est sûr que ça va marcher en théorie
ça va marcher
en théorie je traduis je te donne
environ 5% de chances de survie
comme ça qu'on devient un délit sans
rien c'est juste que tout ça c'est très
beau et excitant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]